all in the same room 50 delegates from
the government 50 from the opposition
and 50 from civil society haggling over
the names on the last list the reason it
took the best part of two years to get
this meeting underway the UN will
oversee their work to come up with a new
constitution for a post-war Syria but
it's special envoy admits it's going to
be a most difficult task I know that it
is not easy for all of you to be here
together in this room and I respect that
I know that there are deep feelings
among you reflecting the deep feelings
among all Syrians above the state of
their beloved country after nearly nine
years of violent conflict the two
co-chairs pledged to work together but
the things they focused on in their
addresses were no surprise armoured
cause Bari said the government will
continue its fight against what it calls
terrorist groups Liberec our fight
against terrorism is an ongoing war that
we started before our meeting we
continue this fight during our meeting
and we will keep up the fight until the
liberation of the last inch of our
precious homeland for the opposition
Hadi al bara who also attended previous
rounds of talks in Geneva that failed
raised the plight of those Syrians being
held in custody we must achieve the
release of all detainees at the hands of
all parties and to discover the fate of
the missing and the forcibly displaced
we must respect the right of families to
know the fate of their loved ones one of
the most difficult issues in drawing up
a new constitution is the role of the
presidency the government delegation
here no they must be loyal to President
Bashar al-assad a man who's shown over
the last eight and a half years he's
prepared to use the most ruthless
tactics including barrel bombs and
torture in his prisons he's unlikely to
want to relinquish power just because of
decisions made at these talks James
BAE's al Jazeera at the UN in Geneva